the keys to a productive life can be
found in science that's according to
author James Clare who says breaking
down tasks into small achievable goals
leads to higher productivity think about
that for a second he applies Sir Isaac
Newton's laws of motion to achieve these
targets clear rights Newton's three laws
of motion can be used and as an
interesting analogy for increasing your
productivity simplifying your work and
improving your life more than four
hundred thousand users subscribe to
clears newsletter I'm one of them on
habits and performance his work has been
used by the teams in the NFL NBA and MLB
as well as leaders of Fortune 500
companies James clear is here good
morning good morning so tell us about
your new the new work that you're doing
sure so habits are really important
because they compound over time so you
know if you were able to just get 1%
better each day for a whole year you'd
end up almost 37 times better by the
time you're done with it so they seem
like really small choices right in the
moment it seems like nothing in order to
make these choices but over the span of
our lifetimes they end up making the
difference between who you are and who
you could be all right the New York
Times is coining that term essentially
micro progress to describe breaking it
down into small units to achieve a
bigger goal what's a way to start that
sure so I like to talk about the
2-minute rule and the idea here is that
you want to downscale your habit until
it only takes two minutes to do so for
example going for a run might be down
scaled into just tying your running
shoes or folding laundry is down scaled
into fold the first pair of socks or
started yeah the idea is that we often
optimize for the result but instead we
should optimize for the starting line
not the finish line yeah you said don't
look at the big picture of success you
should really concentrate on just do
something well if you when you achieve a
result you really only change your life
for the moment like achieving your goal
you know if you have a goal to clean
your room for example then your room is
clean now but if you don't change the
habits the packrat sloppy habits behind
that goal then you're gonna have a messy
room two weeks from now why our habits
important James well habits of course
give us the results that we want so they
you know they can help us earn more
money
lose weight or be more productive but
the real reason that habits matter is
because each action that you take is
like a vote for the type of person that
you want to become so they they help you
embody the sense of being that type of
person each time you write you are a
writer each time you play the violin you
are a musician each time you workout you
are an athlete and so your habits are
the method through which you embody your
identity and develop your sense of self
your self image we are what we
repeatedly do tell me if there's a huge
problem I've got let's say addiction to
technology how do I take a massive thing
like that I want to fix and break it
down into manageable pieces sure well I
mean we're all addicted to our phones
you know we have our smartphones on us
all the time where do you leave your
phone out at night in my hand as I
cuddle it with it I mean deal with right
there phone is the last thing they see
when they go to bed at night yeah the
first thing you see when they wake up in
the morning so one thing that you could
do is just move your phone to a
different place to charge it so you
could charge in the bathroom for example
set your alarm there and then the only
goal here is just to reduce the amount
of time that you're on mindlessly browse
while you're laying in bed what about
those initiating actions that cause me
during the day to go change it do I have
to get habits to get me from being
triggered
well these cues are everywhere right and
so for example if you look on my phone
I've tried to reduce some of the cues so
that I have no app screams right and the
goal here is just to increase the
friction a little bit so I can still go
to Instagram for example and swipe over
and then it's inside this nested folder
but I just don't want to do it
mindlessly and so the whole idea with
habits is to try to increase the amount
of friction that are associated with bad
habits to put more steps between you and
the bad behaviors and fewer steps
between you you're the expert at the
table what's your best habit do you
think I feel probably the best one is
that I leave my phone in another room
until lunch each day and so that gives
me like three to four hours of focus
productive work to just you have any
friends do you have a wife but make a
habit of reading his newsletter that's
yeah yeah I'm raving about we kept using
Sir Isaac Newton so we should at least
point out quickly you know one of those
three laws bright objects in motion tend
to stay in motion yeah getting started
it allows you to develop the most
effective form motivation which is
dress and so if you can see yourself
giving these small wins then you have a
reason to continue working and if you
start in just a small way then you're
gonna want to keep going thank you that
was my goal this year it's like don't
worry about just get on the treadmill
and walk for 10 minutes and all of a
sudden you're there it's 30 minutes it's
40 minutes
you started it just started thank you
James they're very nice to meet you